the nintendo switch launch lineup could  look a little different than what we  were expecting I'm Tony and this is your  newly released gamespot news update it  appears that Zelda breadth of the wild  won't launch alongside the console in  March this report comes from both  Eurogamer and blogger Emily Rodgers  who's insider information on Nintendo  has been proven correct in the past the  change is apparently caused by  localization on the bright side the same  report from Eurogamer says the console  could launch with a new Mario title we  saw a glimpse of new mario game play in  the switch reveal trailer but no game  has been announced just yet we'll have  to wait for more from Nintendo speaking  of which the company's big switch  presentation is set for January 12 will  hear all about the console specs price  launch date and launch games then stay  tuned to gamespot for more and for all  the biggest nintendo news you're already  in the right place